As a startup it can be challenging
to set your marketing goals.
You don't want to waste your time
on things that you'll do nothing
with later.
This is why setting your goals is so
important.
Consider this.
>> Please tell me which
way to go from here.
>> That depends a good deal
on where you want to go.
>> I don't care much where.
>> Then it doesn't much
matter which way to go.
You're sure enough to get somewhere,
if only you walk long enough.
>> You need goals that are realistic and
attainable.
It's fun to spend a few minutes
thinking about your vision and
high level goals, like to be the most
visible brand of the industry.
Or, make sure every potential
user wants to talk about our app.
But as a startup, you probably don't
have enough time to spend full weeks on
wording your high level goals.
You'll want to jump into
your actionable objectives.
I want you to take this opportunity to
quickly draft two actionable marketing
goals for your own app idea.
There is no right or wrong answer here,
but we still encourage you to try it.
If you don't have your own app,
help Lauren and
me by drafting two actionable
marketing goals for Embarkment.